- Gentleman with the slightly
lighter colored hair.
(audience laughing)
Which is a polite way
of saying the older man.
(audience laughing)
GG, are you a fan of hip hop?
- [Crowd Participant] Victorian country?
- Not really.
I want to convince you.
So if you could hear a hip hop song
of anything in the world,
what would it be about?
- [Audience Member] Donald Trump.
- Donald Trump?
What about specifically?
Well, people are very upset with you.
(audience laughing)
I'm gonna come back to that, okay.
Someone over here said Victorian
something, what was it?
You're covering your face,
which means it was you,
what did you say?
Victorian what?
It was something you blurted
out and now you regret.
I don't understand.
- [Crowd Participant] Victorian.
What did you say?
- Are you all okay everyone?
(audience laughing)
So reticent.
- [Crowd Participant]
Victorian century rap maybe.
- Victorian century rap.
Oh okay, yeah, no,
we shouldn't serve this
lady anymore alcohol.
(audience laughing)
Okay, a Victorian rap,
that's a good suggestion, I like that.
- [Crowd Participant] I
thought it was something
you would really know.
- No, don't be embarrassed,
that was a good suggestion.
Oh my gosh, I feel, please be okay.
(audience laughing)
Back of the room, what
would you like a rap about?
- [Audience] Bleecker street.
- [Crowd Member] A haberdasher.
- [Woman In Crowd] Little Dicky.
- [Audience] Bleecker street.
- You're shouting Bleecker street,
and the other person's
shouting a haberdasher.
Okay, the Bleecker
street haberdashery, ooh.
Victorian rap.
So far guys, you're coming up with words
that are too long for
that woman to pronounce.
(audience laughing)
Let's come over here,
what would you guys like a rap about?
- [Male Audience Member] Foreskin.
- Well, because I've said
foreskin that feels obvious.
What did you say?
- [Participant] Going antique shopping.
- Going antique shopping,
aren't you all such a
prim and proper bunch?
(audience laughing)
What are you on the hunt
for while you're antiquing?
- [Participant] Lamps.
- Lamps?
- [Participant] Yeah.
- Antique lamps,
of course you are.
Antique shopping for lamps and
Bleecker street haberdashery,
Victorian rap.
People over here, hello,
what would you like a rap about?
- [Audience Member] Wile E. Coyote.
- You said Donald Duck and
you said Wile E. Coyote.
Oh, here we go.
Different, different universes,
but I'm sure we can bring them together.
Donald Duck and Wile E. Coyote,
antique shopping for lamps,
Bleecker street haberdashery
and Victorian rap.
Now my friend, we came to you first,
we disappointed you with Donald Trump.
But we got Donald Duck, so that's close.
What have we decided to rap about?
- [Crowd Member] Daffy Duck.
- Daffy Duck?
Okay, I feel like the show
is gonna go on too long
if I'm like, "No, we need something else."
Fine.
So Wile E. Coyote versus Daffy Duck,
Bleecker street haberdashery,
antique shopping,
the Victorian rap and Daffy duck.
This then lovely people.
What's this discussion going on here?
Oh okay.
- [Participant] Pennsylvania Dutch ya.
- No, no, no, Pennsylvania Dutch?
Yeah, is that what you're saying?
- [Participant] Yeah.
- Cool, the Pennsylvania Dutch,
maybe we'll throw those in as well.
Fucking hell.
Right, this is a freestyle,
a rap made up on the spot, not written.
The Amish, okay, thank you for clarifying.
I think they're different people really.
They look they're same.
This is gonna be a rap,
and Red and Jeremy
they've proved themselves
to be such magnificent
musicians throughout the show
and their careers.
And they're gonna lay down
some sweet, sweet beats
for us to have some tasty treats.
Let's do that.
(audience whooping)
- [Audience Member] I know right?
- Ooh
Feel that bass, that's
vibrating through my buttocks.
(audience laughing)
Nice.
♪ It took a while for man on the side ♪
♪ When I asked T he was like DT ♪
♪ Now he's saying Duffy, that's a DD ♪
♪ Like a cup size ♪
♪ Duffy Duck looking different to Donald ♪
♪ He provides mainly
just the black feathers ♪
♪ Pull it all together like
a white ring at the neck ♪
♪ Looking clever ♪
♪ Pretty smart, pretty suave,
like a duck James Bond ♪
♪ That's the Duffy there, if
I see him on the duck pond ♪
♪ Maybe he got an entourage ♪
♪ Maybe followed by the
guy in the sailor suit ♪
♪ That's Donald ♪
♪ Why's he wearing no pants
with the white feather ♪
♪ I like the little top hat ♪
♪ It's kind of not leather but fabric ♪
♪ And if he sees Mickey he's like ♪
♪ Yo Donald, would you come quickly ♪
♪ Donald can't speak, but Daffy can ♪
♪ So maybe he's got the
linguistic skills of a man ♪
♪ But Donald's like quack quack ♪
♪ I don't know how to do the voice ♪
♪ And Wile E. Coyote, road
runner, not by choice ♪
♪ He's just driven, an insane urge ♪
♪ For getting that
horrible, fast legged bird ♪
♪ Why are we usually on
the side of road runner ♪
♪ I like the guy with
explosives, much funner ♪
♪ He drops a (indistinct) but oh bummer ♪
♪ It crushes him down like
oppressive heat in the summer ♪
♪ And listen, yo, we
should keep in touch ♪
♪ I'm a fan of Pennsylvania,
I'm loving the Dutch ♪
♪ They're coming over from Holland ♪
♪ And Rotterdam and Amsterdam ♪
♪ And saying, we be coming over here ♪
♪ What's the plan ♪
♪ To build a big barn ♪
♪ How you like me now ♪
♪ Patterns on the side,
milking all the cow ♪
♪ One day I really get my wish ♪
♪ No one should ever
confuse us with Amish ♪
♪ They don't understand ♪
♪ They're like it's not right ♪
♪ They'd be frightened if they
saw tonight with the lights ♪
♪ Whoa, these should be done by candles ♪
♪ Lip from flattering angles ♪
♪ Or maybe take a chance with the lamp ♪
♪ Assure their Amish lamp candelabra ♪
♪ Out beyond the little
alleyway and I'm seeking ♪
♪ I'm looking for the right
lamps when I'm antiquing ♪
♪ I know how you feel,
the lamp that I love ♪
♪ I look down there, I stoop from above ♪
♪ I get the other shoppers
out the way and I shove ♪
♪ But then it's got one
of those shit old plugs ♪
♪ How am I going to use this ♪
♪ The plugs whack ♪
♪ I can't get a modernizer
thing to adapt ♪
♪ It won't fit in the wall ♪
♪ It won't fit in a socket ♪
♪ And so I just put it in my pocket ♪
♪ Then I rock it out the door ♪
♪ And the guy's so elderly,
he chased me down the street ♪
♪ But he fell for me ♪
♪ Shattered his femur and his thighs ♪
♪ And all the rest, his pelvis ♪
♪ This was kind of nearby ♪
♪ Yeah, I should tell this ♪
♪ I'm seeking, antiquing, on
street that be Bleecking ♪
♪ If you want a nice cloak,
you and me speaking ♪
♪ I'll be walking in, want a
cut that's flattering for me ♪
♪ I go, hello tailor the
haberdashery is open ♪
♪ And I've spoken with the chap ♪
♪ He says yo Chris,
put this on your back ♪
♪ I'm like yo, that's not the
way you expect to be greeted ♪
♪ But still I look good
in my satin, I seek it ♪
♪ Take it home for my wardrobe ♪
♪ It's not whack, but 200
years ago wore mainly black ♪
♪ Why, my husband died
and I'm adoring you ♪
♪ What's the name ♪
♪ Not amused, name Queen Victoria ♪
♪ See me here ♪
♪ Yes, I'm the queen ♪
♪ Everybody else now,
you fools are obscene ♪
♪ I'm the queen upon the throne
ruling for the longest time ♪
♪ Nobody's got garters
that are longer than mine ♪
♪ I don't like seeing legs and ankles ♪
♪ Don't like seeing it ♪
♪ Yo, I can't stand you ♪
♪ Queen Victoria, yes ♪
♪ Drop the raps into you ♪
♪ What we going to do next ♪
♪ Invade India. ♪
(audience cheering)
Yeah.